[Musique]
ce liquide bleu contient de l'huile de
cuisson et de l'huile de vidange pour
les voitures selon les spécialistes il
serait plus efficace que l'air et l'eau
pour refroidir les serveurs dans les
centres de données très polluant ce
système de refroidissement ne consomme
pas d'eau donc pas une seule goutte
d'eau elles consomment jusqu'à 70%
décret cité en moi donc ce qui est assez
intéressant elle ne fait aucun gaz à
effet de serre et surtout elle est
ininflammable ça c'est très important
par rapport à au datacenter qui peut
exister aujourd'hui grâce à ce système
de refroidissement par immersion la
chaleur dégagée serait également plus
facilement récupérables elles pourraient
être redistribuées pour des logements ou
des entreprises aux alentours existante
depuis plus de dix ans aucune société ne
s'est décidée à l'industrialiser
l'objectif affiché d'yttrium est donc de
convaincre les 7 à 8 millions de data
centers dans le monde que cette
technologie fonctionne ça va vraiment
être un show room un démonstrateur en
français et on va vraiment l'utiliser
pour présenter cette technologie à je
dirais à tous les acteurs qui voudront
la découvrir on n'est pas obligé à
chaque fois de construire les bâtiments
neufs ça ce n'est pas une obligation on
peut juste adapté de manière très simple
datacenter existant avec cette nouvelle
technologie on n'est pas obligé de
repartir de zéro à chaque fois voilà et
l'investissement est vraiment minime par
rapport à les data center aujourd'hui
énergivores c'est un projet extrêmement
innovant la région équipe de france est
une terre d'expérimentation d'innovation
et donc pour nous il est tout à fait
naturel de venir accompagner
financièrement des projets qui peuvent
pas être plus risqués c'est entre rôle
est de les aider a vraiment réalisé ces
projets qui créent de l'emploi qui sont
très performants en termes
d'environnement d'impact environnemental
le coût total de ce projet est de 20
millions d'euros avec une participation
de la région ile-de-france de 40% le
bâtiment devrait être opérationnelle en